you
within the human body proteins carry out
a range of functions essential to life
this year's Nobel Prize in Chemistry has
been awarded for the mechanism of
protein degradation in cells we found
that the small protein which its role is
to take the proteins for the addition it
is a kind of a death steak or kiss of
death it was called it's the first time
that Israeli scientists have received a
Nobel Prize two of the laureates are
based at the Technium the Israel
Institute of Technology in Haifa
Avram Hirsch goes research into protein
degradation began when he was a student
I went for a postdoctoral training
period in San Francisco and then there
was a big lab which worked on the
synthesis of a certain protein so I
asked as the head of the laboratory
Gordon Tompkins can I work on something
else because looks too crowded so he
said why don't you work on the
degradation of the same protein the
protein in question was ubiquitin a
small protein isolated in 1975 it was
known that proteins in cells are
degraded when they are not needed
anymore
but no one knew how it was done so I saw
that there is a need to understand the
chemical processes that selectively
degrade the right protein you know out
of the out of the tens of thousands of
proteins that we have a cell is one
certain protein is selected at the
certain time and degraded the right hand
erin chicken OVA joined the project has
Avram Hirsch goes graduate student his
interest in science began in childhood
I went science and medicine all my life
I mean I remember where as a kid I took
the most precious Jewish book which is
the Talmud and we had a copy of it huge
books a series of books at home it
belonged to my brother and I dried the
flowers in them I took flowers and I
made my collection my brother came home
and he got you know he exploded I mean
he thought what this crazy kid is doing
he takes flowers from the mountain wet
flowers and advised them in the Jewish
Talmud I mean it's not only that it you
know it really damaged the books but the
contrast he couldn't understand this
huge convert so my love to science and
tomato has been there forever
having identified ubiquitin as playing a
key role in protein degradation Hirsh go
and Chicana vez set about trying to
define the mechanism of degradation this
discovery came about during a series of
sabbaticals at Fox Chase Cancer Center
in Philadelphia where they worked with
the American scientist Owen Rose Harris
ago at that time with his graduate
student C honover came to came to our
lab and summers and occasionally for
whole years and we and they elaborated
the different steps we found that the
small protein which we discovered here
its role is to take the proteins for
degradation it is a kind of a death
stack or kiss of death it was called by
the Swedish Academy through their kiss
of death for the protein but I should
say it is the kiss of life for the cell
because it's very important to degrade
the right protein the right and
otherwise the cell gets out of control
so it is small molecule ubiquitin that
decides which protein will be executed
will terminate its life at a certain
point the laureates worked out that
proteins to be degraded in cells are
tagged or labeled with a ubiquitin
molecule the labeled proteins are fed
into structures within the cell called
Proteus ohms the cells waste disposal
units it's here that they are cut into
small fragments and destroyed the
medical implications of this discovery
are far-reaching because proteins play a
key role in cancer
if you're going to understand the origin
of cancer you've got to understand the
control of a protein that influences the
DNA ubiquity and media that protein
degradation which is the system that we
discovered seems to be involved in
almost every basic process in life and
that is because proteins are involved in
almost every bladesey processor in life
and that that includes a control of cell
division which is very important because
when cells get out of control then we
have cancer so the surprise is the
chemistry price because it was done for
understanding how how the chemical
processes are in the body but actually
the the big implications are for
medicine this contribution to chemistry
and medicine is the result of a
remarkable team effort we are all the
team I am noting very well iron chef
Anna where was my graduate students for
five years and now he's my colleague at
the Medical School we discussed everyday
you know the the his results and
actually should do a next experiment so
I know him very well
unlike Hirsch go and she caneva Owen
Rose has never specialized in ubiquitin
research it was not my whole life so
therefore since it wasn't my whole life
I didn't feel that that I was really
that instrumental in it I am very very
glad that the urban Rose was included in
the most prestigious price of all and he
deserves it because he had a very
important impact it at the most crucial
period of his research